you have to realize when you're asking
to do to live a one-percent life that
you need to do 1% things if you're a
purebred Asha floor you love the dark
clouds when people start looking for
somebody else to be at fault whether
it's the government or their aunt or
some or their boss they always lose
Juanes or get a mentor
what's up the leap nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best Gary Vaynerchuk and
how to live the 1% likes mentor me Gary
also if you want to know what Gary other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 250 4 days
I will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
the reason people don't put themselves
in a position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one that love the dark clouds everybody
wanted to be an astronaut one day like
it every kid that been looking at these
good-looking kids they all wanted to be
astronauts and pilots in 1957 what do
they want to be now entrepreneurs I mean
this is my moment
and by the way it'll be fun and in nine
years the world will melt
everybody will not be an entrepreneur
anymore it won't be cool they'll blame
entrepreneurship for the melt and I'll
still be an entrepreneur because that's
what I've always been that's what I am
now and that's what I'll be to the last
breath if you're a pure-bred on the
floor you love the dark clouds you
understand that the fake
entrepreneurship Bureau we live through
loves the sunshine when it's good and
happy and easy but if it's in your DNA
if you actually are not something you
know exactly why the upcoming year of
dark clouds is going to be very
important because at the end of the day
this is a game based on merit and if you
don't know how to navigate those storms
you can't be in all time on war
I love the dark clouds because they're
part of the problem
rule number two play outside the rules
you know I hate things like nice guys
finish last
where it's just not true nice guys might
be losing at halftime but they win the
game
nice guys always win it's just so crazy
all this fodder in the system that isn't
true
all the faking it to you make it as a
fashion brand that's agreed or at what
every single twenty three-year-old male
in the world is doing which is fronting
on Instagram because boys want girls you
know and so like I'm just unbelievably
passionate in trying to what I realized
about myself was oh the reason I won and
I'm good is I've never played in the
vortex I've never played in the actual
rules of life I was an F student when
every immigrant was supposed to be an A
student because education was the way
out I launched an e-commerce wine
business in 1996 right like that was I
have a sneaker thanks for wearing them
like I've always done things that don't
make sense
I play outside of the actual game and
that has been where all my happiness has
come from and so many things have become
obvious to me by playing outside of the
rules playing outside of the rules is
the best and that's where I want people
to understand we are pandering to so
many things that just aren't true rule
number three stop complaining nobody is
gonna cry for you they have their own
tears one thing one thing I'm positive
about is how are Y negative complaining
is and how much I'm trying to suffocate
the practice of it I really have been
fascinated by people that have changed
their mindset into understanding that
everything that is not going well right
now is their fault it has been
remarkably
important to me in understanding that
everything that I'm not happy about has
is on me it's it's a remarkably
interesting brain twist the amount of
energy spent on things that you can't
control versus being accountable to what
you can control has been a huge
separator for me in the last four or
five years as I've dug deep no question
the quickest way to happiness is
accountability when people start looking
for somebody else to be at fault whether
it's the government or their aunt or
some or their boss they always lose
Fulop before finds you're why all the
time because they're doing it for the
money I think the bigger question is
what do you want the money for
is it blocking and insecurities that to
get the girl is it is it is because
you're trying to amass as much as you
can because you don't actually don't
like working and you want to live the
reason so many people say fail in life
and business is their model is let me
get the money so that I can enjoy and
relax they think of it it's like
hoarding it and then eating it all
overtime so a retirement and uh listen
it's such a bad way to because then
you're feeling the pressure of like
massing so that you can then enjoy I
think the bigger question is like what
do you up to like why are you doing it
like what's up I just think a lot of
people are trying to achieve success
and use fame or money as makeup for a
situation that they're just not happy
about like you have to figure out how to
make your day in and day out happy ruler
if I chase underpriced attention my
entire career what allows me to be here
today what allows me to gleam and be
audacious about owning a professional
football team is very simple i chase
underpriced attention I chase properly
priced attention and I completely punt
overpriced attention simple I know that
everybody in this room does things for
eight to ten hours a day every day of
the day of the week the month the year
on things that no longer bring as much
value as it did six nine 14 years ago
that helped you get to this point I know
that there's somebody in this room that
if they started a BB podcast I know that
if somebody in this room who had never
thought about producing content or media
if they started a podcast which they
don't even have the beginnings of a
thought of how to do that right now
but the good news is you literally go to
google and you type in how do I start a
podcast I know that if somebody here
started a podcast for this industry and
put out an episode every week and
interviewed a thought leader in this
industry that even though only 700 to
1500 people would listen to it because
it's obviously very niche in its content
that it would be the differentiator of
growing their business that it would
lead to lead gen that there are people
that they're trying to chase to get the
account that in turn a year later would
be chasing them to be a guest on the
show which then would inevitably lead to
them getting the business my friends
please understand over the next period
of time as I talk to you about some of
these nuances that I am NOT a
technologist that had I not been in
business that I wouldn't want to have
necessarily an Instagram or snapchat or
LinkedIn account it doesn't come natural
to me it's not necessarily what I want
what I want is to sell stuff when I
want is to run a successful business
what I want is to win and to me if you
sit in this room and you do not realize
how extreme the internet technology
revolution actually is you become
vulnerable and rule number six the last
one before very special bonus rule is do
1% things you're asking for a 1% of 1%
life so far I've heard I didn't want to
eat and put out stuff and deal with no
feedback for a year or two I don't want
to spend the three or four hours to like
learn it cuz it seems like there's so
much you have to realize when you're
asking to do to live a 1% life that you
need to do 1% things dude I've worked in
a liquor store for 15 hours a day 7 days
a week for years and somehow people put
that as like part of my narrative but
don't give it the respect now the bonus
cut from Geary and how to work hard and
smart that I think you can enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
take you in your life for business and
if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what are your 1%
things number two what's your why and
number three where do you need to stop
complaining how much time you spend a
month
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it in a day
zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I'm
guaranteeing because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about do you understand
that's I mean look that's the answer the
answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a 1%
life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special
it's very special trying to build a
business for yourself everybody's doing
now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer everybody's doing
pulling it off trying to be a footballer
an actress got it so you're trying great
pulling it off is hard it takes
everything time and smarts you mean
seven I'm glad you said it that way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable
it's the 17 other Alice
I'll give an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus course to driving your car
if you want more garyvee check it out
how to make $1,000 a week garage sales
flipping video made the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
if I was really doing this right right
I'd make I'd make a thousand a week easy